wer würde er mit drei oder mehr toren 44
stunden ins patchday ich meinen ersten
kommen zu einem neuen video wir sind ja
meine seite ein bekanntes gesicht max
mit dabei aber auch zwei etwas
unbekanntere gesichter ein pizza will
jakob auf eurer rechten seite ja nach
unserer linken
die frage ist warum machen wir das ganze
hier seht schon gerade zettel mit namen
drauf wir spielen heute wäre der mann
kennt das ganze schon mit youtube
geworden youtuber passen immer auch dass
sie keinen scheiß über sich erzählen
aber wir haben heute zwei nicht youtube
mal dabei und die man sprechen wir die
ganze sache ein bisschen zweiter werden
denn diesen tagen wurde bekannt dass sie
uns auch mal gerne bei mir
wer würde zuerst seinen führerschein
verliert als 23
schon die an oder hat ja die nato
überhaupt die sache sagt jan kann keine
autofahren war am main / und ich hatte
angst um mein leben stirbt ja nicht so
dass mein auto gefahren und hatte ja das
paar küssen soll ich die stelle das auto
über 55 essen das habe ich aus versehen
gern gegeben was hier gebaut damit hatte
ich glaub du willst verlieren kommt ein
knöllchen und text erst mal diskutieren
und dann ein schon dass kein bock in der
von für euch also ich hin muss er das
wort alkohol dazu ins spiel bringen
könnte durchaus mal
so passieren das soll jetzt weiter
ausbildet
ich bin jetzt langsam aus der probezeit
raus auch durch 21 ich hab's auch noch
nicht gemacht aber wenn man 21 ist bin
ich der meinung das ist gesetzlich so
gab es versucht zu tun nicht gut so aber
nächste frage dass endlich gut wäre die
er für klicks ein geheimnis von einer
person verraten 12 ok warum ist aber so
übrigens im februar jeden tag ein neues
video deshalb kleben jetzt schon auf den
ersten blick in der beschreibung last
ein arm oder ford auf den posten content
des monats februar und das gesagt wer
würde er sich selbst auf bildern im
zimmer einer 11 23 kein einziges bild
der pause zu machen
die autobahn wird von dir er klappt
hochnäsige teixeira mit
du würdest wahrscheinlich irgendwie so
sondern bildhauer in auftrag gegeben
dass er nicht so nackt aus steinmeiers
wird das bereits aber ich habe
tatsächlich ist schon sehr hoch
ich bin jetzt doch es gibt schon
plattform auf den bilder objekte die er
dem anderen die freundin ausspannen das
ist natürlich eine sehr günstige sagt
aber hier müssen aber jetzt hat er
nochmal umdrehen angst 23
die realität war hier ist es nicht
so ich habe noch nie in meinem leben und
freund ausgespannt
ja die dauern wird er machen würde ganz
ähnliche regeln vor der bayern haben oft
über themen geredet und du weißt du das
nicht machen ich weiß das nicht machen
würde die frage ist ja nicht wer will
das jetzt machen sondern wer das am
besten machen oder das gestört ich würde
ich hab dir schon von situationen
erzählt wo ich nicht gemacht haben sie
ist erst dann aber ich suche die frage
gerade nicht werde er mit drei oder mehr
toren geführt weil sie schon in
speckstein oder muss überlegen musste
der musik
wir werden natürlich sehr deutlich die
ehrlichkeit kommt langsam wieder der
halter wir halten das thema freut ich
mach doch mal wer wenn nicht wir
vielleicht wirst du auch einen banner
wenn die frage ist ja wer würde er also
genau die kölner fans machen genau hat
auch keiner von uns gemacht genau diese
frage werde die er bei l4 mitspielen 12
also sagt meinem jacket okay also ich
muss dazu sagen sebastian ich haben
schon mal so gespaßt dass ich damit
machen sollen erst am konsum aber ich
muss ehrlich sagen es aus dem
freundeskreis hätte jakob das schon am
ehesten drauf also dass schauspieler
vielleicht aber doch der wird gerade ein
guter schauspieler sein ganz gute story
jakob hat auch mal in köln war karneval
glaube ich sowieso getan als wäre aus
amerika ebenso rtl heute müssen glaubten
ihren studenten viertel noch ausgelassen
in los angeles gibt es so etwas nicht
ich hab ihnen halt wie angenommen weil
also jan wäre halt der prototyp domain
verkäufer im fitnessstudio um ein
einbeiniger freund auf steroiden liebt
meine oma war dann noch ein weiter weg
also ich habe sebastian noch zwei videos
darüber mache natürlich das stimmt auch
er hatte er auf einer party einen liter
milch hexen um mädels zu beeindrucken
ist eine sache dann muss ich auch schon
wieder so lange über jahre bereich klar
ist wie ihr angebot haben will es
einfach tun
diese 20 jemals mit wildwechsel
mal gucken was wir so antworten ich bin
sehr gespannt der 321 maxiformat ich
würde sagen dass das format ebay
angehörigen
das ist böse das ist richtiger bullshit
okay also ganz kurz eine topstory so es
wurden auch schon säulen getreten um
mädels zu beeindrucken der wohl
unterstellt dass das bistum will jetzt
zu beeindrucken das würde die
überarbeitet
interessant ist hier weil ich das doch
wenn du alkohol trinkst deinen gemüt
sich verändert und die ist erst seit es
keine andere antwort eingefallen als
maximum aber es ist ja nicht eingehalten
die an würde kein liter milch hexen
sondern nur neu gewählte auf den boden
schmeißen und europa auf einer party
dass ich zu überwinden habe ich nicht
mal mit einem liter öl übergießen 50
euro nicht abstoßen werde er nach zwei
monaten beziehung einen antrag machen
geist 23
naja ich habe jedenfalls im wasser es
kommt auf das man vor dass sebastian
wurth gruppe von studio lassmann morgen
nach indien fliegen oder
1/10 ist ahnungslos und wenn der satz du
hast du denn da das ist die richtige
da gebe ich den ring ich habe das letzte
jahr ausgewählt wir haben natürlich nur
so mal dass er an kathrin götze ohne zu
zögern heiraten wenn er werde dafür
mercedes s klasse bekommt also ist jetzt
ein bisschen anders als die frage von
vorhin aber er war einmal bereit den
menschen den er nicht kennt
zwei wochen brauchte dafür der s klasse
3b hochzeit war gesehen haben als das
gefallen aber da brauchst du keine s
klasse um an karten götze zu heiraten ja
was wäre so ein für das add on von ihrer
familie parkett ich habe max gewählt
weil max prinzipiell mensch ist dass
eine person anspricht mit der zusammen
kommt und dann so acht jahren mit der
zusammen ist und wichtige heute das
heißt wenn max mit der person zwei
monate zusammen ist dann geht von
mindestens fünf jahren
[Musik]
wer würde er ein ganzes jahr 365 tage
ohne geschlechtliche handlungen aus
kommen und sagen wir paris bordeleau 5
321 200 euro
ich hab dich ausgewählt weil du anderen
prinzipien fest korrekt und das ist er
wäre auch eine prinzipien
wo man bezahlt da muss ich auf jeden
fall danken also noch fähig ich würde
jetzt nicht mehr der verschieden
verschwenden ich werde jetzt nicht ins
risiko mit der gehen kann ab ob die
nächste frage werdet ihr eine frau an
der bar ansprechen da ist auch wieder
reifliche überlegung gefragt da etwa
halb halb zwischen jan tut mir der
kirchlich geschwenkt geschwenkt aber ich
bin kein anspruch mehr hab ich dann auch
gesagt dass diese branche und ist gehen
häufig oder vergehen zusammen fahren und
vor guten jahr weiter sebastian noch
etwas schüchtern aber das ist ja nicht
mehr also nicht negativ gemeint dass
sebastian ist ein offener mensch
geworden studierende können die frage
wovon sind werde er an einer virtuell
bei welchen themen 88 auf und so gar
keinen sinn
[Musik]
ich glaube es hier konnte das machen
wollten und verkehr dabei ist uns das
auch noch ein ja gut die leute
eigentlich das video an dieser stelle
die ihr gerne sehen schon vorbei aber
dann gab noch eine frage aus dem
publikum reingekommen
er führte er eine fremde zuletzt
behindert zu helfen
überhaupt 312 das wasser teilweise
sofern die leute hier sitzen youtube
oder instagram missionen in der
beschreibung von links checkt hier über
das gesicht auf jeden fall ein für euch
vorgeschlagen das video ab bis zum
nächsten mal und bleibt einfach geil
mehr kann ich nicht sagen